[Music]
you're gonna play fan OHS in Avengers
infinity war you were entering this
franchise I don't know if you realize
what you're getting into because Andy
and I did a week of shows at comic-con
this is a world that takes that stuff
extremely seriously now that you are
playing fan OHS this is gonna change
your life no no I was in I was in
Albuquerque I was doing a movie called
Sicario and I had rented a house it's
always nice to people like Sicario and
at the end of my block with the house
that I from the house that I rented was
a comic book store and I had done the
little teaser in guardians of the galaxy
but I hadn't really gotten into it and I
didn't know a lot about Thanos I was a
comic book guy and I loved you know Hulk
Thor that kind of thing but so I went in
the comic book store wanting to get more
information and there were three guys in
there one was on a ladder and he was
changing a light bulb or something and
then there were two other guys behind
the the whatever the counter and I
walked in and dude they went apoplectic
I mean it was like doo doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo and I was like what is the
deal and they were like they know Stan
Oh Stan us
honestly yeah it scared me it honestly
scared me because when people I mean
it's it means something it's their whole
childhoods are based on this stuff right
they wouldn't have made it had it not
been for Santos they would have walked
off and been orphaned somewhere yeah but
because of Manos it saved their lives in
their heads so they see you and they and
they don't you think that's is true for
all actors that play superheroes is it
just particular to thinner so it's only
me no no but I think Nano says I'm just
starting to understand what it what a
big deal fairness is and it's probably
the greatest decision I've ever made in
all seriousness because these guys I
mean these guys get together Feige and
lowest Esposito and all the guys at
Marvel they rent a house I don't know
somewhere in the desert they just they
barbecue and they come up with this
amazing these amazing trajectories that
last like five ten years so I'm supposed
to meet with them next week they're
gonna tell me what I'm doing I'll say
yes sir and I'll leave and I get to play
Thanos for like a few years yeah it can
be fantastic